okay we'll commence the meeting
um for the product financing projects
committee for today 21st of February
um just acknowledge those that are
joining us on
live stream
um and welcome to the to the meeting so
first off we'll cover off apologies
um I have apologies from councilor
Campbell and mayor Clark are there any
other
apologies for the meeting
I hope you're accepted okay I can know
them okay thanks Karen and thanks oh Mia
Khalifa's writing
yeah I've got an easy to seeking but we
actually just got a call yeah
or attract that apology from the Mia
Clarke he's just a rod
okay
um are there any Declarations of
interest in relation to the items on
their agenda today
no okay thank you
okay public forum there's no one in
public forum today that I've been a boy
still
that
okay cool so the first item four and
agenda is the minutes of the finance and
projects committee meeting held on the
24th of January move those
thank you Leslie
seeking the berry thank you any
oh sorry all those can I make one
comment Mr chair um just said uh
I haven't actually reviewed the document
a briefing document it's noted in the
minutes
it's an action
that you have you haven't reviewed I
haven't reviewed it today but I will
ensure to do that okay thank you and we
note that
okay all those in favor all right
against carried thank you
okay the city streetscapes cost update
in Russell
welcome Russell thank you for your paper
some afternoon and thank you Mr chair
um
my report today really just um I guess
updates us as we are approaching the
completion of our project um we continue
to look for a date that's uh at the end
of March that's our story our our
ongoing
Target date and just happy to say that
we continue to track within our budget
or the budget that's allocated to the
project 20.8 million so we managed a
number of risks and I guess the weather
has been reasonably fortunate for us for
the last while
and the progress is good so we're still
going to get there at the end of marches
we were committing to
able to receive any questions thank you
any questions
ringy
thanks chair Russell the the original
pricing for that stage one was was
around was it 18 or something and then
there was another amount for
uh play or something and we're using up
the play stuff to keep it under budget
the overall alcata budget is the 20. the
whole project for that stage yeah
so the sacrifice of some play stuff was
there
correct but we continue to have some
contingency that we are managing so I
guess the opportunity could be to
consider those at the conclusion of the
project right right thanks
do we know what the numbers on that
contingency roughing
um don't have it with me sorry but
okay sorry Aaron
sorry the only piece I was just going to
clarify was that councilor pottinger is
correct around the play
um but also around the shelter component
was the other element that we sought
approval to essentially reduce the scope
to remain within the budget
thank you no further questions or
comment in relation data report
okay can I have a movement that we
accept those recommendations with the
net please thanks ringy and seconded
thanks Leslie okay all those in favor
against carried thanks Russell
okay the next item is the quarterly or
performance second quarter performance
um update so Rhiannon
well
thank you chair
um so I'll speak to the non-financial
performance and then hand across to
Patricia to speak about the financial
performance
um so the service levels continue to
track pretty much similarly to last
quarter
um so that Trend that we saw last
quarter of a returned to visitor numbers
across the council is holding strong
currently 65 of the 99 performance
measures are currently on target I'll
just focus on the changes since the last
quarter some of those are relating to
roading just having now some data in
there and sadly about fatal road traffic
accidents which remains an area of
concern
um in solid waste there's some new data
that's become available and that Trend
in landfall rubbish has just become an
area of concern
um in the packs and Recreation Area
probably just one thing to flag around
that customer satisfaction survey it's
so close to the
um the edge of the target it is within
that statistical variance so really
would put no not much
um
focus on that change in the Parks and
Recreation
result and the library is now reporting
that it's collection performance due to
those issues that they were having with
uh transport of materials has now come
right so not not huge stories from last
time but I'm just saying that those
trends that we were seeing are
continuing
thank you any questions in relation to
the report
ring
well maybe about early asking this
question because I've asked for other
data that we expect in April but that
that plus 503 000 in solid waste because
that's generated through the ribbon
collection
rather than because anything taken to
the transfer if you take rubbish to the
transfer it's being paid for so that
that's an unnated cost but appearance in
the redbin collection I imagine
um as I understand it and I can seek
some clarification but I understand
that's a combination of the red bin as
well as the contamination through the
myth that's primarily around those
tightening up of requirements of what's
acceptable
um versus the Murph performing at a
different level to what it has
previously
so we don't have any concerns with that
it's primarily around that more critical
requirements around what's accepted
you know it's just the variance
obviously this can again like last year
was 700 000 increase this is just um
obviously this is waste Nets
jurisdiction to to try and minimize this
um we're getting the idea when we might
be having that first away stamp meeting
uh so there is one as I understand it
the final the schedule agenda is just
being finalized at the moment I actually
thought something may have already gone
out but I'll check where that's at okay
thanks okay
so just on that matter so when when will
the council
see a report on that
on the way snip issues and challenges
and choose what I've done is as chair of
infrastructure I've asked separately for
a last three year prior covered month by
month analysis of redben data okay what
what covert had an effect on
um and uh and other Trends as well as
the contamination from the recycling so
that's going to come about April or
something like that and that'll show
hopefully show us
what's happening in invercargill
um I just can't believe
that red bin is increasing at that
dramatic
rate but
the data will hopefully shed light on
that because it's compounding isn't it
did you say 700 the previous year 500 so
and that was straight on top of rates
that was unexpected yeah
yeah it's a concern um I think what I'd
say is that the the overall trend up you
know there's definitely still an uphood
Trend
um in the amount of waste going to
landfill
um it's not a significant upward Trend
it's generally sitting below five
percent
um but it is there I think what we've
spoken about before though is that yes
that's going to have a financial impact
on households
um and we all know that there's a very
strong I guess you'd want to say policy
being set by central government around
increasing that cost of waste generation
in an attempt to try to drive down waste
generation yeah so just carrying on from
there I think it's important is that the
figures I asked for also were the the
increases from the gate fee at Avi lime
and that's made out of four components
it's a b lime's fee it's the government
admission trading scheme tax on every
ton
it's a fee from wastenet and
administration fee and there's also the
30 Levy imposed by government to
re-inject into waste minimization plans
so that's the gate fee and that's been
moving up but what's been worrying me is
the increased volume and the last
infrastructure meeting this is where it
still doesn't make any sense is that the
presentation by Peter Nolan showed that
we were tracking downwards we were the
average we've been working on for the
last 10 years is 650 kilograms per
capita and we were down at 480 and
that's why this doesn't seem to make any
sense that we've got more tonnage but
um yeah that's what I'm looking forward
to yeah
that all those points will be come to us
through infrastructure correct correct
okay yeah got but obviously there's one
inch on vacation right and it's creeping
so
okay
Patricia oh I'll switch over to the
financial performance so pretty much for
the first six months of the year we're
pretty much on track against budget but
we do note that revenue is down slightly
um
but it's just a timing issue at the
moment there is nothing to be concerned
at within the revenue and the
expenditure so we're pretty much sitting
on par
um
and we have put through some some small
uh forecast changes as well in relation
to Capital delivery
the um
given some of the changes requested by
Council in future years that's an impact
on their current year and we will be
forecasters based on a
59.2 million dollar candle spend that's
down from 79.8 that we had in the annual
plan
at the moment that is progressing
against that
that plan
thank you
the other questions in relation to the
financial
mere clerk
um sorry just to go back on the previous
report which was the um
um
the quarterly two performance result
um just on on page nine of board books
on page
two of the report it talks the roadmap
to a renewal it says up there Rugby Park
Surrey Park and
city streets states to our pause but it
seems to have missed the fact that we've
also paused the
upgrade this morning which is a cab
building
um I can speak to that
um
mayor Clark that is simply because this
building is not in the roadmap to
renewal is a separate project okay thank
you and the last issue is on page four
of that report for me which is the
capital program has decreased the
forecast amount of borrowing required
this year by 15 million
um is that a year-to-date figure or was
that the overall figure for the year
because I would have thought when you
looked at the programs that we've got
pause
there's a um much larger
Capital Pools I guess and what's the
signal there so is that just a
bit so the pause here today yeah okay
thank you
and look just want to comment on the one
particular part of the roadmap to
Renewal delivery and that's Anderson's
park now the renewal has been done with
the building earthquake proofed and it's
now up and running as a brilliant asset
I went to a luncheon a couple of weeks
back put on by the Caterers there and
there was a ticket of the thing it was
completely sold out and Brilliant a
brilliant day under the big elm tree at
the back and it's everyone got to walk
through the place I think it's
it's brilliant uh that it's now in use
and um being managed
um they actually sell up the tickets
first then they do the event so there's
no
um there seems to be obviously
profitable for those doing it so so it's
well done I think
yeah it's good feedback thank you
okay any other questions in relation to
the financial
component of the report
okay so that being the case can I have a
mover in a second to receive those
recommendations with them
um ringy and Helen
okay all those in favor
against carried thank you
so next step
projects management office update Lee
welcome
sure
we'll just uh do a quick uh highlight
through the different projects
so city streets is Brussels also spoken
to a bit earlier the team is still
tracking an end of March completion
and we're just watching that with close
eyes obviously the weather has been kind
to us of late a little bit of a turn in
the forecast ahead of us there's a lot
of small items that will need to be
picked up you know in those last weeks
so um but there's a bit of confidence
now that
we'll get we'll get to the end of this
one so yeah good good to see the good to
see you coming to an end
uh steadstreak stop Bank we've got a
little bit of a delay with the whales
Tales proving to be a bit more of a
technical challenge welding that up
um but the uh the guys are working
working well on that we have the um the
locker ends installed now so this is the
final piece of artwork still to go in
place the drive period we've just been
through we pour some of the planting on
Airport Ave as well so for obvious
reasons and I understand once the
weather gets a bit better the team will
crack back into that so I believe March
now for the install of The Whale's Tale
which is a little bit later than that we
wanted and then some sort of formal
opening the team are working on
um sort of mid to late April I believe
for that
and the Project's tracking well to
budget with a small return back to the
program forecast which is great
some water main
so stage one we're just about there all
the pipe is just about in the ground
we're literally weeks away from
um putting that last sections in the
ground which is uh great we're out of
the way of the wakatagi
um roundabout works on time so we
haven't got in the way of them which has
been great as well stage two we've
closed the tendering on that and we're
working on that tender at the moment and
I obviously can't talk too much about
that and that's still proven to be a bit
of a challenge
um getting stage two across the line but
um stage one is and the drill shots have
gone gone reasonably well for us a
little bit again a little bit later than
planned but some poor ground conditions
and a few other bits and pieces but
generally I think for a project that
size is it's gone it's gone well for us
uh rubber Park so stage one as I've
previously reported is complete uh the
final documentation sitting with the um
building control uh Team stage two we've
um
start to scope that up so we've had the
engineers and that through the main
stand we've got a structural structurals
so our structural uh set of drawings
there for that and we've also been asked
to look at um the lighting of the pitch
and the plan is to bring a report back
to council a little bit later on in the
year that has all the costs and looking
at lighting and looking at the next
stage for approval from Council
uh the cab refurbishment that project
also been paused while we gather some
more information and bring a report back
to council stage one is complete and
what we've currently done contractually
is pause the designers so we're not
spending any more money on that design
space at the moment and again we'll
bring that information back to Council
in a couple of months time
and that would just go through all the
stuff that we've done with what we've
done recommendations to our best to move
forward
uh project 1225
quite a few different fronts open on
this one so obviously we had the first
Concrete Port at the titsby the first
ring beams of the foundations of import
an excellent Milestone uh 1225 the main
design team has furnished us with 11
bids
so we've been incredibly busy reading
through them and we're just progressing
through that tender process and again
because it's a live process I don't want
to talk too much into that detail great
to get such a huge response from the
market from here in New Zealand and
overseas so um yeah no a great uh a
great result and we'll work through that
uh financially tracking well um tips
free storage program uh building is on
program and also our design elements are
on program as well for 1225 so yeah
really happy with that
left boat ramp the PCG which is a mix of
staff and external stakeholders have
settled on some pontoon designs which is
awesome we've also done some
geotechnical work around the bay there
to understand the Rock and bits and
pieces so the designers have progressed
in that really really well so we've
we've sort of agreed now what the
pontoons will look like how they'll
function so the designers are well
underway with that and we look to bring
a report back to the community board
showing them what the final designs look
like the next big big milestone for us
now is to get the consenting for the
West Jetty sorted with environment
Southland they're giving us a Good Steer
on that and then come back and then go
to the market should I say with the
designs and get that priced up and and
crack on so again
um last year we struggled a little bit
with the whole consenting piece but we
got there with that now and we're we're
well underway so again happy with um how
Bluff is tracking for us
and I'm finally on the list year housing
Innovation again running probably a
little bit uh slower for us
um for a different for a million
different reasons
um but we've got resource consent
approved and we are hoping that we'll
have building consent approved very
shortly we had a considerable number of
rfis come back to us which the designers
have answered back to the team and yeah
really really looking forward to uh
getting that out we've had to have a
tender in the market we've had two
respondents um show favor so we're going
to put that pricing back to those two
respondents as soon as we have building
consent approved so again I've surely
Amber on this uh it doesn't actually
carry through on the risk for some
reason but it's just in the schedule
this we're just tracking a little bit
behind where we wanted to be with that
so that's a real snapshot of all the
projects and open the table for
questions thank you Lee it's a big body
of work on the questions
I've got a couple
um
just in terms of your
the Optics of that presentation there
what I would find useful with within the
um spin to date
against planes being today okay yeah so
we can get a good view particularly with
some of those larger projects around is
there a gap between what we thought we'd
be spending what we have spent either up
or down
um I think that'd be a good good thing
for us to see
um and that if that's how that will
secondly with respect to rugby perk or
note rugby Southland made some statement
in the media around doing a partnership
with the ICC around some development at
Rugby Park have we had any
contact with rugby cell phone around
that or
um it probably would be ones I could
probably hand over to Steve on not on
the pleasure point of view do we know
anything about that yeah thanks uh
through you Mr chair um look my team uh
working with rugby Southland and I've
done that since the item report which
initially talked about the multi-use
function and so we're continuing to work
with them
um I don't think a lot of conversations
had over the last month or so but we
will be re-engaging with them shortly
okay cool thank you
and then finally just from my
perspective with respect to 2025 in
what's happened in the North Island are
we foreseeing any impact on that project
in relation to that I can't think of
what they might be but yeah I think for
the tidsbury facility
um we actually have that very same
conversation on Friday with the
contractor they've well procured all
their steel they're well procured all
their insulated panel
um Linings and bits and pieces glazing's
been ordered so they're they're well in
advance for all the procurement
activities so yeah no red flags there
and obviously the main museum piece is a
is a piece on paper design piece so we
should get well clear of uh of any
impact from the North Island yeah I just
wonder if we look at when we'd be
procuring for the main Museum and how
that might phase into when they're going
to probably be doing quite a bit of
heavy lifting up north
yeah no it's definitely going to be
something we need to consider I suppose
a lot of the uh impacts in North is
infrastructure um civil sort of stuff
which again not really our Kepler fish
no and until we really Progressive
design it's going to be hard to know
um what materials are impacted and
whether it's lbl glass you know yeah
yeah yeah so so a bit of crystal ball
keep a watch yeah definitely watching
brief okay thank you
no questions
okay can I have a mover and a second of
police to receive
that please leave Ellen is
all those in favor
against carrot thanks Lee yes really
good okay
um next item is the
Financial update
I think Patricia's going to present this
for us you're going to stay we own yeah
thank you I'm lazy um okay so this is
the financial report at the end of
December in relation to debt and in
relation to debtors it's the end of
January
um so at the end of December the
borrowings were sitting at 104 million
and we were sitting with 47 million of
cash so we're a net debt of 57 million
it's pretty much where we expected to be
we do note that array a weighted average
cost of debt is still down at 2.34
percent
but which is lower than last quarter and
you think that's slightly perverse but
what actually we repaid some debt that
was actually at much higher rates
but we're gonna find that it's going to
go up steeply in the coming quarters as
we have got some maturities at quite low
interest rates and we're borrowing it
over five at the moment
so we've gone from one extreme to the
other
um
then we've also as planned just gone out
to the market and borrowed 15 million
million for a capital it's to fund their
Capital program so spend we've already
done
the in relation to where we sit and
within our treasury we are still got
that small breach of Treasury policy in
relation to hedging the volatility and
the interest rate markets at the moment
and that's most significantly from when
Bank hope did that report for us is that
we're holding a wait and see approach to
see where it comes and we're going to
look and then each quarter we're looking
at wins the right time to go and do some
fixed
or floating as the case may be
and in relation to ditters Things Are
tracking as I'd expect
we always expect slightly higher
outstanding debt coming off that
December quarter just because people
with holidays don't tend to pay us
directly on time as they might and other
parts
in relation to rates debtors
um
that number's coming down tends to come
down as we get down to the fourth
payment
um and then we and we are actively
following up a lot of debt at the moment
and there
and I've provided we've provided the
additional um
expenditure in relation to the minimum
wage increase which has been announced
by the government that is going to have
some effect on us and we're
taking it up by a dollar fifty an hour
the minimum wage increase
so we are still working through what
that impact will be but it is Eric um
opinion is that it will drive through
the wage claims so we'll need to look at
that during annual plan and we've
included the sensitive expenditure
for the last since the middle of
September
open to questions thank you any
questions in relation to that report
I have a couple
um just
endnote you know
if you expect the rise around Christmas
time and that that it is but it's quite
a bit significantly more than this time
last year isn't it
I've come through and the public
excluded
um paper yeah
yeah and then with your reference on
page
um about the links those that don't
agree with us with mortgages do we know
the data of how many
people
that are in a risk with us that do have
um
they're still in a reason have a
mortgage
mortgage Holder will have been contacted
right so we do do that on a regular
basis so once they go into a risk
because under the rating act we can
actually get payment from the mortgage
company and there's a mortgage company
claims yeah so we do that on All
Occasions or
not on every quarter so we tend to do it
once or twice a year yeah
yeah towards the end of the cycle yeah
tends to be around actually around the
December January yeah but maybe
back for the previous year but we always
have that recourse yeah and that's our
first recourse yes
give me a piece
of History yeah okay now the questions
okay can I have a mover and a second to
move thanks in
thanks Alan all those in favor all right
against carried
okay do you well that's really an
appearance isn't it so it's
the business enhancement program
Michael welcome
to nokoto cheer committee members and
Mia Clarke
this is hopefully my uh first and
potentially last presentation of this
business enhancement program as such
I've brought the information services
manager here Mark redcliffe as well so
he can listen in and if there's any
detailed questions might be able to
support and answering those questions
like I say this is the first time this
has been up to this Committee in fact
it's the first time it's been back to
any committee at all Council previously
this funding was allocated as part of
the annual plan process to enhance the
internal systems and processes Within
Council
it's pleasure to bring this up and show
that we have been doing work in this
space and there are Improvement projects
on track
I'll refer
to our overall table and and what shows
that we are spending throughout the
course of the year but that doesn't in
my my turn just spending the money
doesn't actually show progress from that
perspective you need to look at each of
the projects and show what we're
achieving from that perspective
but also note as part of the first table
we have presented to the committee that
there is no spend allocated to it
strategy we do have a number of projects
underway for internal system
enhancements but they have yet to get to
the stage of implementation so they will
be towards the end of this financial
year as they start to eat into that and
they'll probably carry over into the new
year some of those are around our phone
system and a review of how we're
providing our hosting or network of
services
some of the key milestones in relation
to our project you would have seen that
over over time that the property
digitization project which was actually
one of the projects that was started
before we put the business enhancement
program together but we wanted to have
the overall governance internally across
that make sure we're keeping a watchful
eye on it so that project has been
brought into the fold we did initially
Have a scheduling
issue and relationship project but we
have now put that back on watch We're
pleased to say we have worked with our
partner to get that under control so
it's a pleasure we say we've got that
back on track from our perspective but
onwatch
digital preservation that's an
interesting project for me because that
actually sets up the ability for
historical records to be stored and have
the certainty that we are storing those
records in the correct manner
um the
the manual form of storage is uh easier
to do from that sense in relation to the
digital and quite often when people do a
digital program of such they Overlook
the fact that we need to store those
records in the correct manner we've put
that in place we've completed that work
so we're comfortable we've now got the
process in place going forward and the
creation of our digital record to meet
compliance so that's what pleasure I can
say that one we've also completed a
review of our corporate file plan that
particular project was looking at what
what we need to do in relation to
document storage going forward that will
have another implementation component
going as we roll out the document
storage of their digital record
our supply chain project we finished
first phase of what I would call
our business P2P or procure to pay
process
and that first phase was the pay
component purchasing aspect we've we
completed that in phase one this is the
middle component which is keeping
putting the contract
document storage in and actually putting
in a contract management process in
place
we still have and I know we're doing it
in reverse order we still have a
sourcing and supply project to complete
so as part of this we will be doing the
scoping of that
the reason we haven't put that in scope
is we do have some Automation in there
already and it would be replacing
existing tick where in the mindset of
trying to replace our manual processes
first then look at what we need to do
about replacing our existing Tech in
those cases
so that project did have an issue as
you'll see in the report in relation to
we didn't quite get the scoping right
from that perspective I think that's why
we have a governance board in place to
make sure they are achieving the
objectives that did come back and we
have reviewed that one of the things the
governance board has decided the
internal governance board is that we
should make sure there's a review so
this committee can feel confident that
we're making having lessons learned from
the previous Financial project of
Technology one and that we are going
ahead
with the improvements as we outlaid in
our first review report so we've asked
that that be included into this project
the next project that we've got on that
list is talking about hris which is
actually a human resource information
system
hris won't mean a lot to a lot of people
but it means a lot to the organization
versus the the start for two things a
communication platform for our staff but
also the ability for our staff to
interact at a digital sense
I've highlighted before when I presented
the initial BEP program that we've got a
110 staff out there approximately that
do not have access to this Council
digitally
this will allow that to occur it doesn't
matter that it's a council device we
have that security arrangement in place
that it can actually go over the
internet from that perspective
so this particular project is important
in getting that in place and getting the
certainty around information flow
internally
it will also look at replacing
potentially I say potentially you've got
to do a review on each of these projects
the payroll system as well to make sure
that we have linked through data right
through for reporting
the last project that I've got on this
list is rates online it's exciting to
say that we are in the stage of piloting
that internally first with our staff
from that perspective to make sure that
it's operating as we would hope and then
we will look to have a wider Arch on
that and get that out to our customers
and Community as soon as possible I'm
sure that will be a great Advantage for
our ratepayers as we go forward we will
finally be able to do rates online which
will be exciting I think from that
perspective I think the breadth of
projects you see that we've started off
in the enhancement program a little bit
of inward a lot of getting the
foundation right and a little bit of
getting something out there for our
customer I think you'll see a flavor of
that the whole way through the program
trying to make sure that we are
giving a experience for the customer at
the same time
on that note I'll hand over to questions
thanks Michael
any questions
oh
thank you Mr chair um when we originally
talked about this
whenever that was it seems like a long
time ago the one of the things that you
brought up was about the digital
security how have you found the
experience over the last years that
improved or are you catching more people
trying to infiltrate us and as this
system do you think more robust than
what we've had in the past
on that question I might actually hand
over to the information Services
thank you for that question
um security cyber security is is front
of mind with all we do um cyber security
uh is is a component of each of these
initiatives we also have planned several
uh other specific uh security uh
implementations
um which we're just waiting for some
internal resource to to be in place uh
to spearhead those we've certainly seen
a continued attack on on invercargill
city council digital resources
um we we have to be
um we have a great experience in each
system that we put in place to ensure
that that security really is uh core to
to each of those initiatives
um so I'm I'm pleased to say we haven't
had any any intrusions or any
information
compromise or any downtime to any of our
systems over this last period
oh just to follow up I think it's
in front of my mind is that what we're
seeing overseas is
um infrastructure attacks
um so Water Service delivery things like
that
are we
it lesser or greater risk at the moment
with how our services are delivered then
other places so how much of what we do
is
um accessible to computer attack
in terms of water delivery Etc we did a
rigorous piece of work
two to three years ago to to separate
out the three Waters infrastructure to
ensure that they are in their own
entirety entirely resilient to to attack
or any leakage from uh from invercargill
city council corporate resources they
remain a key Target you tend to get
the highest targets of those with direct
Financial rewards so financial
institutions are high on the list and we
have I guess flown below that radar
because we are we were not able to
provide Financial benefit
um to to the the bad guys
um but we we ensure that all of the
services that operate our three Waters
environment are maintained according to
a tight renewal schedule to ensure that
it doesn't present any vulnerabilities
to attack
thank you for that Mr chair yeah it's
good in this one thank you any other
questions
no
okay thank you for your report um can I
have a mover and a second to please for
receiving the recommendations thanks
Darren and seconded by Ellen all those
in favor I against carried
okay
so we now need to move into
public excluded
just one issue and it's remiss of me not
to roses and I know we have accepted the
minutes of the previous report but back
in the um
um sensitive expenditure report there
seems to be a
bit of a glitch so Patricia might be
able to help me with that so it's on
page 91 of board books
um yeah and so um down the bottom of
that expenditure second page there is a
cost
um for the Bolton hotel for September
that's in December last year given the
election was two months earlier than
that is that just a late payment coming
through that's a late payment coming
through that was uh sir Tim's coming
Queen's Memorial was just the that's the
period in which the expense was recorded
so it only hit our system in December so
just a second request into that up above
that about a third of the way of the
page there is um a queen's Memorial
accommodation of the James Cook hotel so
is that it was given I do believe it's
probably given the
number of people in Wellington at that
time two different accommodation
providers were needed for the two nights
accommodation okay
thank you
that's midnight I just wanted to chip
down yep okay thank you
move them to public excluded thanks
Leslie can I have a second look at that
thanks Barry
all those in favor
aye against character